So, that is it.
That is going to wrap up this video tutorial.
And in this tutorial, we covered what Niagara is.
We talked about Niagara being Unreal's solution for any visual effects, no matter if you are
a film person or an architect or a game developer, you can find some use for Niagara.
We then looked over the various Niagara content examples and then took a look at the Niagara
interface.
And finally, we put all this information together and created our first Niagara effect, which
was some lit smoke that used a sub-UV to help simulate the smoke actually moving even more.
So I hope you learned something and I appreciate having you here and I will see you next time.